[Música]
[Aplausos]
cuando hablamos de ventas todos piensan
en manipulación o presión señores ya eso
evolucionó queremos vendedores
profesionales que tengan el conocimiento
la capacidad y esa pasión por vender el
vender se acabó ese cuento de que el
vendedor labios o ya no ahora tienes que
darme algo que me atraiga algo que al
final diga wow
yo quiero ese producto o ese servicio
para eso todo vendedor ya tener cuatro
puntos importantes clave que son
sencillos en la parte de mercadeo
producto que es producto productos
tangibles o intangibles son aquellos
productos que tangibles los físicos
celulares camisas carros eso lo tangible
lo intangible los servicios eso que
brindan los servicios el precio porque
hay importante el precio el presidente
porque eso es lo que la gente está
dispuesta a pagar por tu producto tu
servicio
o sencillamente cuando tú cuestas
se oye feo pero no es cuando tú vales
cuánto cuestan cada uno de ustedes cada
uno usted se pone su precio como uno
alza baja ese precio por el conocimiento
que tenga recuerde señores el éxito de
cada persona es la educación entre más
tengamos educación y conocimiento
estamos dispuestos a que la gente pague
lo que sea por nosotros
otra de las p la plaza que es la plaza
es el lugar donde vas a vender tus
productos tus servicios en esta era
nueva o esta nueva era es sencillamente
es tengo que estar las redes sociales lo
que están en internet si no estás en
internet no existes entonces hay que
evolucionar y por última de las 4 p cuál
es la promoción cuáles son las
herramientas que voy a utilizar yo para
que la gente me conozca dónde que brindo
que ofertó ahí está ok y ahora una
pregunta a cada uno de ustedes alguien
sabe cuál es la diferencia entre actitud
conoce
de actitud con él
con c viene de conducta de
comportamiento y con p de pensar s
pensar que es de nuevo el conocimiento
la capacidad yo en century a destreza
habilidad ya está talento
otra pregunta cuál es más importante
actitud concede
las dos es un matrimonio no puede estar
separadas tiene que tener las dos esa
conducta con cesc y ese pensamiento que
es el conocimiento ok y para esto
sencillamente le va a las cinco técnicas
para usted de vender uno conoce a tu
cliente 2 cuál es tu valor agregado que
vas a aportar a ese cliente 3 tu
argumento de venta 5 cuál es eso que tú
necesitas que la gente diga wow y el
último la propuesta irresistible de
ventas con eso cierra la venta gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]